but we're going to begin this morning in
kenosha wisconsin after a very
controversial visit from president trump
he toured the damage and posed for what
critics called
photo ops and what he suggested was a
show of support for the community in law
enforcement
after recent unrest there the president
also painted a dark picture of a city
torn apart by conflict even though most
protests there have been peaceful
including a protest
event that happened during his visit he
did not meet with the family of jacob
blake
our mulalengi is in kenosha again for us
today mola good morning to you
well good morning tony you know the two
glaring issues and topics that are
consuming kenosha
are the jacob blake shooting and
systemic racism which of course sparked
the protests we've seen
over the last week or so now instead of
focusing on the causes of those problems
the president
instead focused on the symptoms
of those problems the violence and the
destruction that have rocked this city
this should never happen a thing like
this should never happens
in kenosha tuesday president trump got a
first-hand look at the damage from the
aftermath of the police shooting of
jacob blake
kenosha has been ravaged by anti-police
and anti-american riots mr trump focused
on the violence
instead of the peaceful protests for
racial justice you believe systemic
racism is a problem in this country
well you know you just keep getting back
to the opposite subject we should talk
about
the kind of violence that we've seen in
portland and here
and other places it's tremendous
violence
the president was greeted by protesters
but also by his supporters
i do think it was good that he was here
to see for himself firsthand
what has been happening over the last
week here in the city mr trump never
directly mentioned jacob blake
nor did he meet with blake's family we
need a president that's going to unite
our country
and take us in a different direction
on tuesday the blake family joined a
justice for jacob rally in the
neighborhood where he was shot
the rally offering services often
lacking in the african-american
community like
voter registration and covid19 testing
we're using it to talk about
jacob and stand up my son
since he can't stand for himself we'll
stand him up
blake's father jacob blake iii said all
that matters
is his son's health we as a family
only care about jacob we're not
political pawns we're not
for political photo ops all that we
care about is the recovery of django
plate
and blake's sister insists the justice
they seek
goes beyond jacob just as for black
people as a whole
we want to be able to walk around in our
skin
and not feel like we've broken the law
already benjamin crump
is the family attorney we would have
liked to engage with him about
reform to address the systematic racism
that causes from city to city
state to state the extrajudicial
killings
of african-american people by the police
well jacob blake senior is also calling
for immediate police reform which you
know is a cry we hear from protesters
pretty much every single day
he's also calling for the arrest and the
immediate firing of the officer
who shot his son that officer is on
leave during the course of the shooting
investigation meanwhile jacob blake
remains in the hospital he is recovering
paralyzed from the waist down gail